merci d'être avec ma chérie on est en
direct en ce jour férié c'est que du
c'est connu qui jean michel mr merci
vous avez fait quoi y est j'ai bossé là
dessus parce que je croise un jour
s'appelle marion vous êtes avec une peau
non j'ai bossé l'acte une petite
financière ce moment aux usa où il ya
quelque chose là je les ai sentis on
amour en commun c'est les chiens et
l'admission qu'elle a deux chiens et
comme elle était confinée deux chiens
dans un petit appartement mais
s'épanouit au téléphone très compliqué
et caetera et je dis bah vient chez moi
j'ai une terrasse j'ai la chance d'avoir
une terrasse je vois là et je suis dit
voilà comme ça les chiens au moins
pourront s'arrêter à ça sera moins
compliqué pour toi que c'était et du
coup elle m'a dit c'est jeu j'aime je
roulais pas abuser j'y vais dans
quelques jours et de deux jours trois
jours quatre jours et puis elle est
restée les deux mois mais ça s'est fait
tout entre nous avec les chiens entre
nous j'ai comment vas tu me fasses ça va
super moi j'ai joué à huit heures du
matin hier au tennis pendant deux heures
je vous prends quand vous voulez aux
bibelots vous jouez extrêmement
sérieusement avec géraldine lequel de
vous deux ans porte la partie très
sérieusement dans votre intérieur
surveillait n'y j'ai pour habitude
vraiment de respecter géraldine et je
vais dire la vérité c'est géraldine qui
va le dire et jradi mais c'est très bien
elle sait très bien qui va gagner ce
match et c'est très bien ce qui va se
passer
c'est très bien que ça va rien changer à
notre micro
[Musique]
vous croyez vraiment vous pouvez pas de
prochain mais en ce moment je joue
beaucoup
[Musique]
bien sûr parce que vous voulez
jour un coach vous serez tout seul dans
tout ça j'ai pas besoin vous êtes à la
fois percutant puissant dans ce robuste
on avait beaucoup de puissance dans
votre jeu et en même temps vous êtes
très vicieux vous avez rien une bonne
main et donc vous faites beaucoup de
chocs beaucoup de petites balles
merdique derrière le filet c'est mal
fait tout comme on forme des placements
étaient nuls il est objectivement très
fort parce que vous avez su adapter
votre votre jeu au mien et à mes amis
faiblesses devait jouer n'ont jamais
avec le guen invitera les mégots tout
dans la vie tout court la force dans les
cuisses non mais non
[Musique]
et bien afida turner que vous connaissez
c'était à 19h heure française trésor
américain 2h heure chinoise publié un
tweet des fans dire français je vous
annonce ma candidature à la
présidentielle afin de remédier au
problème des gilets jaunes et de
surcroît à cette piopolis violents alors
merci afida merci voila voila merci pour
sa personne
afida donc vous allez donc vous
présenter aux élections présidentielles
en france c'est bien ça c'est en france
c'est à dire qu'en fait en premier lieu
je n'aime pas l'injustice
j'ai été bouleversée entre amis mais
aussi bas nous aussi vous savez qu'il
faut 500 signatures de maires sa mine de
rien il faut pas parler nage de 500
maires de france qui pourrait vous
parrainez escaut classer les avoir 300
mais c'est à dire c'est pas pareil c'est
pas des soutiens c'est pas des mères
c'est pas des soutiens les fans c'est
pas des parents adacore à bob sonnac
aujourd'hui c'est la réouverture des
terrasses des restaurants et bars 30 he
has donc forcément on est tous ceux-là
on a tous envie d'être dans la rue moi
d'ailleurs on va aller faire un petit
tour tous en terrasse après faut laisser
pas loin ses cadences la réouverture des
terrasses c'est pour nous et je vous
offre
c'est pour moi un ouais ouais c'est sûr
annoncé pour moi bien sûr c'est pour moi
c'est pas le bébé c'est pour tout le
monde monsieur c'est pour moi pour cette
table la commande et vous mettez des
desserts mettait des tiramisus mettez
des boissons mettez de ce que vous
voulez c'est pour moi c'est cadeau pour
la reverso dias et bonbons vraiment toi
tu es de bonne famille franchement qui
fait bien les cherry a le petit bébé qui
est là et bien je vous fais des gros
bisous champador sympathie chapatte pour
mes amis chant pas d'ici ajar était
quelqu'un qui veut du champagne
champagne madame champagne
madame bonsoir madame comment ça va
non c'est pas mal d'astuces pour vous
c'est jean-charles jean-charles je
t'embrasse il a son charme voilà qui ont
enfin soir une petite bouteille pour la
dame la voulait voir quelque chose non
mais bon ces trucs pour mes amis je
passe du ruc avoir hérité avec la
lentille optique on cas c'est truqué ou
plus on peut savoir les sûretés paimpol
donnerait pour servir mes amis savent
pas ce qu'ils n'ont pas d'alcool bangoka
tu veux quoi tu me dumas la limonade ou
des malades en tout cas l'un sur la cub
merci monsieur ries merci c'est pour moi
c'est cadeau bien très bien d'où tenez
ou vendredi mais masque à la base les
besoins de mal
on va les voir encore ce qui se passe en
terrassant parce que j'adore et hier
hier on a offert d'aider voilà les
boissons des trucs là aujourd'hui on va
aller plus loin regardez ce que j'avais
quoi
mais ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta mère
nous étions amis mais toi tu t'es là
imola c'est non mais elle était là et
c'est pour moi c'est cadeau je veux
qu'ils mangent tous les jours à l'absolu
ces questions dans une course cycliste
si je double le deuxième en quelle
position je suis deuxième
deuxième c'est sûr qu'on n'est pas
premier c'est gagné c'est quand même
hyper important les sous vêtements chez
moi je prends moi je propose que tout le
monde montre son caleçon et voilà c'est
la fin d'émission à l'esitpa mal
parce que vraiment on va rigoler non aux
vendeurs exigent bij pas possible si les
dictateurs 4 pour l'instant je vous
explique on peut juste faire ça avec une
caméra portable c'est à dire il ya un
cadreur et moi j'ai un micro pour tout
le monde
l'émission d' entrave a su peut pas la
diffusion qui stocke honda a plaisanté à
tik tok qui ne manquera de voir ce qu'on
peut faire
je vous explique mon là un problème qui
n'a pas été réglée de la journée et jeux
divers de la journée mais c'est bon
t'inquiète pas on n'est pas à ça près un
problème qui n'a pas été réglé dans la
journée apparemment on va pouvoir le
régler pendant la pause publicité donc
là on va faire une pause et peut-être
après il y aura les blessures aux aguets
rester sur le qui-vive un tuner su
rester sur sa maîtrise passe quelque
chose
voilà j'avais donc on va voir et après
on fera thouarcé audi sur tik tok un spa
live on est entrain de baron d'apple
youtube
[Rires]